non mi convince preso la parola primo
mio figlio nino benvenuti save the
stories oggi i nuovi studi episodio in
nascondigli snack al cinema dal
controllore terzo episodio lo scorso
episodio secondo episodio vi è piaciuto
tantissimo lo stesso quindi strano anche
questo episodio raggiunti ai 20 mila mi
piace ci sarà anche un quarto episodio
quindi spolli ciotti qua sotto
poi alla fine del video scrivete nei
commenti qual è stato il trucchetto che
vi è piaciuto più di tutti qual è quello
che mi ha fatto divertire più di tutti
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn e
iniziamo subito con il primo trucchetto
primo trucchetto lo avete consigliato
poi nei commenti andrò a nascondere gli
snack da una sciarpa abbiamo quale c'è
il poster pe verde e la sciarpa
grifondoro voi di che casa siete in
questo caso andrà a usare grifondoro
perché si abbina quello magistero e
andremo ad attaccare di snack dentro la
sciarpa poi andrò ad indossare la sorte
sperando che il controllore non sono
accorta quando voi se ne accorgerà ecco
qua ho incollato vari metri all'interno
della sciarpa
ora proviamo ad indossarla crediamo che
non si vedano e che non cadano questi
sono cioccolatini a me da piccolo
facevano sempre gli scherzi ti regalato
200 500 euro e poi erano questi anche
poi stanno questo scherzi
[Musica]
abbiamo berlino non solo per te questi
non si vedono
ok questa volta è caduto solo 12 le o
fissati meglio questa volta non
dovrebbero cadere
spero come mettere la si vede qualcosa
se il mio box il viaggio coprire meglio
ok ragazzi oggi snack nascosti nelle
serp andiamo ora dal controllore
speriamo che non si accorga di niente e
ragazzi c'è un problema e continuano a
cadere di snack
so che cosa avviene l'ha lasciata che
cosa sta tenendo con la mano è un
fortissimo mal di gola
jimmy è meglio se mi per creare subito
altrimenti la potrebbe contagiare
starebbe molto male quindi è meglio che
mi fa entrare ma io credo che c'è un
sacco di consentono al collo non è vero
non ho proprio mai niente
certo non mi convince veduta parola
[Musica]
sequestrati tutti subito un round perso
prossimo trucchetto da una mascherina
per gli occhi semmai che cosa ci fai con
la mattina per gli occhi al cinema dove
dovresti guardare lo schermo e mi
inventerò che il cinema è l'unico posto
in cui riesco a dormire bene qua a una
taschina in cui possa nascondere gli
snack vediamo quanti ce ne stanno e così
qualche tutti i nostri snack o
all'interno della mascherina se qualcosa
che proverò a rimuovere ok quanti snake
ci spero ancora vediamo monetina uniti
mi sento stark guardate si ci sta
guardate un po cocoà la mia mascherina
per gli occhi che nasconde tantissimi
snack all'interno delle qualcosa secondo
voi se ne accorgerà andiamo
ci si si si si si verifica invece
partito di fitto malefica aiuto mi fa
male detto paura neppure si può così
subito ma cosa c'entra realistica chi
male vendo la mia mascherino di monetica
sim bravissimo stai bene ad avere paura
ea farmi entrare senza precari siamo
riusciti ad entrare senza nessuna
perquisizione
vediamo se sono sopravvissuti linee ma
marino non solo per te l'ho detto è
sopravvissuto intero le caramelle
cioccolato si incontrò loro non sei un
corto di niente poi stiamo ora il
prossimo turno prossimo trucchetto per
questo trucchetto userò senti mi inizio
col asili e part of it e di avere gli
addominali qua e di avere i muscoli
mettendo degli ovetti qua non so se voi
se n'era proviamo adesso ammetterli
vediamo come l'effetto magliotto
cambiata ho cambiato maglietta così
scrivere meglio sempre nuovamente
incinta nord chi ama gli addominali per
dare un po
secondo questo perché gli addominali si
consumano intanto guardate un po cosa
sarò per i muscoli delle braccia da due
ovetti di cioccolato vediamo se funziona
[Risate]
altro che braccio di per
il prezzo di popolarità l'attacco
berlino mi sta guardando
malissimo non ci resta che andare dal
controllore e sperare che non si accorga
dei nostri clienti muscoli abbiamo salve
che i muscoli soldi
sì lo so mi sono allenata tantissimo e
sono fortissimo ad es
perquisizione che cosa c'è che non va a
questa volta sono un po plasticosi
questi muscoli
c'è qualcosa di strano in questo muscolo
eri piero ma che succede se si sia rotta
il muscolo così sia o no ha rotto
l'ovetto ma l'importante che sono
riuscita ad entrare senza farmi
sequestrare gli snack
passiamo ora il prossimo pessimo
trucchetto per questo trucchetto ci
aiuterà il nostro fedelissimo aiutante
mascotte della storia family berlino il
cagnolino come ci aiuterà a berlino per
questa felpina cappottino per cani
proveremo nascondere qualche snack qui
nel colletto entreremo con merlino cima
e speriamo che il controllore non si
reco larga secondo me sarà super
divertente che anche merlino dovrà fare
finta di niente
secondo voi si scoprirà proviamo merlino
è già pronta a compiere la sua missione
stato
ecco qua 2 snack nascosti con andiamo a
mettere la felpina giubbottino su
merlino e vediamo speriamo che non provi
a mangiare le patatine
i pop corn numeri da berlino ma sei
bellissimo in giallo non è super carino
berlino e giallo allora gli slick sono
nascosti bene quindi non penso che il
controllore se ne accorgerà
ma anche berlino dovrà fare il
bravissimo attore vero masino al 2000
comando brevità di niente lirio conti
imbarazzi siamo qua con berlino che
nasconde le cose nella pettorina
speriamo che il controllore non ci
scopre ciò che ci sta guardando in modo
strano rinominato quando stai supplente
il controllore ok andiamo chi cioè come
mai lei è piccolo cane ma come
non l'ho riconosciuto no lo guardi
meglio è un cane come coperta addosso
non è una coperta un bellissimo giubbino
giallo bertolina come hanno riconosciuto
fuori di qua
guardi e qua e qua e qua e qua e qua qua
interpreta berlino balboa quante fretta
il karate do wah interpreta un fermo
pauroso è la star di tutti questi film o
le chiedo scusa non l'avevo riconosciuto
prego si accomodi signora star prego io
ti violino che è successo vieni berlino
non dobbiamo andare a pieni bravo bravo
come ha fatto cadere lì per pacco di
patatine che c'era il cane il famoso mi
arrivò la star pignolo vuol dire che me
le manderò io benissimo velino siamo
riusciti ad entrare grazie a te
e infatti grazie alla tua giacchetta
pettorina abbiamo coi nostri mac
peccato che hai persone pacco di
patatine lì per terra
spero che il controllore non se ne sia
accorto in pratica merlino stava
scuotendo la schiera e si è dimenticato
che aveva gli snack dietro e del caduto
pacco di patatine ma almeno siamo
riusciti a prenderli uno bravo merli
dovevate vedere un quasi episodio in cui
nascondiamo gli snack alzino ma anche
con berlino perché è stato super
divertente
lasciate un bel mi piace e ora vi lascio
fa 4 caselline se puoi cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite e buona visione
ciao
[Musica]